let's talk about what happened with joe
rogan because this is where this is
where they made a big mistake with joe
you can't go to the biggest podcaster in
the world who has more ratings than you
do and accuse him of doing something he
didn't do and makes no sense so now we
have the story joe rogan considers suing
cnn over claims he used livestock drug
against kofit they're making ish up
rogan said i literally got it from a
doctor joe rogan gets sick
he comes out and he says hey guys i had
covid you know uh tested positive the
doctor prescribed monoclonal antibodies
zpac prednisone ivermectin and he says
within a couple days he was feeling
great that's a doctor's prescription now
i will i will always state
the cdc says doctors shouldn't prescribe
it it is not authorized or approved by
the fda but that's between joe and his
doctor and i'm like okay if his doctor
prescribed it i'm not a doctor you talk
to your doctor don't talk to me what
does cnn do what did every outlet do
instead of saying that a doctor
prescribed it and you went to walgreens
or whatever to pick it up they said it
was livestock medicine so i don't know
if joe's actually considering suing but
what he said was you know do i have to
sue cnn when he brought this up and i
immediately thought i was like you know
cnn's got to be more careful in that
right nope i want to play for you this
clip i want you to actually hear what
cnn said and hopefully this plays well
but let's let's play it
okay it's not playing at all i think
it's because why is it gotta unmute the
tab that's right i gotta unmute cnn
surprise surprise i have cnn muted all
right let's try this again
okay it's still not making any sound
oh it didn't it didn't work why didn't
it work what the heck there you go okay
that's weird all right we're going to
try this again and we're going to play
one of the world's highest and most
influential podcast hosts joe rogan just
announcing that he's tested positive for
coronavirus
rogan telling his 13 million instagram
followers that he was treated with
several drugs and he included ivermectin
on the list a drug used for livestock
the fda and the cdc warn against using
to treat kovid
on the chiron while she's saying this it
says joe rogan says he has covid taking
livestock drug despite warnings well
that's the mistake you can use
ivermectin for livestock but livestock
is not uh or i remember it's not a
livestream
right right but let's talk about the
manipulation of the media in this regard
it's so brazen i think this is actually
great news for everybody for one i think
joe rogan should sue them and every
single outlet that said this because
think about how insane it would be if
you went to the doctor and and people
corrected me the other day so i'll be
more careful on this one you go to the
doctor and he prescribes you ibuprofen
are we gonna call that dog medicine now
some people pointed out dogs can't have
a lot of ibuprofen
i looked it no no they're the dogs can
in very small doses but they typically
would give them aspirin in small doses
so let's just say this
they do give aspirin to dogs am i going
to claim that aaron burnett
uh was was seen ingesting dog medicine
that she went to a local store in new
york purchasing dog medicine and then
ingesting it shock in a shockingly
insane move no that's insane that's a
that's a lie
so joe rogan is a guy who goes to his
doctor and his doctor's like here's what
i want you to do and she says oh joe
says okay i guess
and now they're claiming he's taking
livestock drug
that is so overt and over the top this
is going to wake people up they're going
to start asking questions about this
because there's no way i mean there's
going to be a lot of bad faith people
who are like dudes for horses
it's it's it's not there are horse
versions of it
there's me a lot of regular people who
are like what well why would joe i love
joe i'm gonna watch him on netflix
well i think
the one thing that rogan said in that
first 14 minutes with segura was
he said
he explained he said they couldn't get
the vaccine through
they couldn't get the vaccine through
the emergency
um
authorization use unless there was no
other
there was no other treatment but that's
but that and you know like when i got it
i took ivermectin
i the doctor prescribed it um no
i would not i'm not gonna say how i got
how i got it and then towards the end of
it i just
there was some other stuff that
another one that trump had mentioned
last year that got demonized and that
knocked it out of my system completely
and i was fine four days later but
the challenge with this stuff is there's
no control when people just decide to
self-medicate or whatever and i suppose
the challenge is that's consent i mean
that's what that's consent that's
personal consent that's me doing what i
want to do it's me doing what i want to
my body the the left complains oh the
reason
everything is so expensive in health
care in this country is because it's a
free market
it's a free market really
i can't order medication that i want i
can't say oh i want to treat myself with
this i should be able to put anything
into this stupid thing right here that i
want to very very libertarian argument
it is a liberal argument but it i mean
imagine if it was a free market so hold
on i got i got to address this all right
do your thing so so
what i would say is
always go to your doctor i'm not going
to question someone's doctor giving them
giving a prescription when it comes to
joe rogan
they're highlighting the livestock the
ivormectin and the problem with that is
he also got monoclonal antibodies which
is uh
does have emergency use authorization
which completely in my opinion debunks
the argument made by joe and the one you
just made if the concern was really that
if they uh authorized ivermectin then
the vaccines lose eua that would make no
sense for regeneron's monoclonal
antibodies if they really thought that
there was an effect that ivermectin was
effective they could just do an eu way
and retain the emergency authorization
for any other treatment they've already
given an eua to as well plus community
has already been uh approved and so i
guess the argument they're saying is
until until it hits market as a brand
the euas will remain i don't think
modern johnson johnson will just lose
their emergencies authorization because
something got approved so that doesn't
make sense you i suppose you could argue
profit motive
but then you're starting to get into you
know
i don't know it starts making more and
more assumptions it could just be that
there was a meta-analysis of 14 studies
showing that ivermectin was inconclusive
there's also a meta-analysis of 53
studies saying that it was showing that
it um
i forgot the word is but long story
short that it inhibited ivermectin so if
these both inhibited covalent
i'm sorry yeah yeah inhibited covalent
sorry uh i guess so my conclusion
ultimately is if there's insufficient
data or if there's conflicting data then
perhaps the answer is simply the cdc
doesn't want people recommending
something they're unsure about because
it might not actually do anything there
might be some people saying like wow it
really worked for me yeah well joe rogan
also got monoclonal antibodies so we we
can't say definitively because there's
no control so when you when you have
someone who who gets sick and then says
i went and took x medication or whatever
it's like yeah well we need a control to
figure out whether or not that was
actually you ingesting something or if
you just beat it so ultimately i'll just
put it this way i think people are
making a huge mistake ingesting horse
medicine in any amount so that's the big
story people like i'll tell you this the
horse paste the the horse ivermectin
sold out in a lot of places that to me i
think is is absolutely insane simply
because
there are there is human grade and
there's animal grade we mentioned this
the other day but i can't ignore
breaking down the points otherwise
people get mad in super chat
when when the when the years when the us
government is regulating something and
it sounds like you're going to be less
of a big fan of a lot of a lot of the
regulations but when they're like okay
we're going to approve something they'll
say hey we can't put this much lead in
it because human livers can't handle
that and it'll make them really sick so
this cannot be approved in this
formulation but for a horse they might
be like oh horse kitties are fantastic
we don't got to worry about that
appearing in it so what happens is
animal grade stuff is very very
different the example i give is that
cats can drink salt water humans can't
we wouldn't simply look at a cat
drinking salt water and be like i can
drink it too so i think people are
making a huge mistake that being said
these news stories about you know the
hospitals being over overflow flooded
and everything are completely bs it was
a huge hoax
ultimately i just say
you know um i i think people can do what
they want to do i suppose uh but when it
comes to any medical decisions i think
it's got to come from someone who
actually talking about otherwise you
fall victim to manipulations
conspiracies and if if if you're willing
to go to tractor supply for stuff
because you read something on the
internet
and you haven't found a good doctor even
a trump supporting doctor a hardcore
trump supporting doctor who who wrote
all these news stories like yo people
can trick you into doing really dumb
things and i think it's not a good idea
to go yeah but here's the thing you can
go into mexi in mexico you can walk into
any pharmacy and say give me ivermectin
give me a give me hydroxyl chloroquine
and you can treat yourself
if people were doing that in mexico
which i assume they are
and they were dropping dead from this i
think we'd be hearing about that all
over the media yeah i i think it
ultimately just comes down to uh
well for one do you trust the media do
you trust the mexican media and i don't
think the issue is death the cdc says
the issue is potential side effects and
the bigger issue like i mentioned is
if there's monoclonal antibodies which
the fda says is authorized it works joe
hogan took that got better and there's
vaccines which they say you know if you
look at israel and some of these other
countries the efficacy has been dropping
another advocating for booster shots so
that becomes a big challenge but
ultimately
do we say hey look at we have a big
chunk of studies that say it's good and
a big chunk of studies saying it we're
not sure it's inconclusive do we
advocate for something we're unsure
about
what if what if people then say i'll do
that instead and then it doesn't work
and things get worse i'm not advocating
for it either way i'm just saying that i
did i did this and i did that and it
wasn't from a tractor supply store and
well that's that i'm talking
specifically about people then like
literally you go to the local tractor
supply there's none left and they have a
big sign saying don't eat it and i agree
you shouldn't i just put it this way
you can't get medical advice from us
no one here is a doctor who knows
we're not also not doing research on
this stuff that's why you got to find
out who you trust from medical
professionals and talk to them i i have
one thing to add to this is is what
makes me uncomfortable right
uh this is a once in a hundred year
you know a pandemic right um
this we're still
in it's in the infancy of researching
covid19 and effective therapeutics and
vaccines and you know now you need one
two three boosters
why
then
while we are trying to explore
scientifically right in embracing the
scientific method with regards to
finding an effective vaccine and
therapeutics why then are we
censoring discourse
that doesn't fit the media narrative
right well we're talking about median
errors it was like you're seeing you
know youtube channels or or censored of
actual doctors
board-certified doctors virologists
epidemiologists they're getting censored
because they're not saying the right
stuff but these are doctors and it's not
like they're they're coming at these
positions from like left field these are
clearly not conspiracy theories
yet they're being censored and i think
what what happens when you do that
is it cre it creates a sense of unease
in people
and and it makes people think that the
information that they're getting might
not be trustworthy because
some
some points are okay to make some are
not now clearly there it's the advice
that's the problem it's when the doctors
like you know brett weinstein did his
podcast the reason he got a strike was
because they were advising people to
take action
like when when joe rogan went on the
show this was one of the first
controversies when uh he said you know
he would advise young people not to get
the vaccine i'm like i don't think joe
should be giving people advice on what
they should do with you know medical
treatments we had candace owens on and
she said he's entitled to his opinion i
said that's true he should be able to
give his opinion
and so
well having an opinion and saying your
opinion are different things he should
be able to have an opinion whether or
not he expresses it it's up to the terms
of service of the the issue was
directly saying you advise people to do
something if joe said i don't think x
should happen
i think that'd be a little bit different
from telling people so so i i'll tell
you this it's funny when you see people
say i am not a financial advisor i am
not a lawyer i am not giving legal
advice we hear that all the time but the
same thing is true for medical advice i
i don't like the idea of like armchair
medical therapy stuff because like
here's my issue
i don't think just because i distrust
the media i should go ahead and just
trust someone else outright
and when i look at the fda's website and
again i i don't necessarily inherently
trust the government i think this was
revolving door policies we've got people
from big pharma they're revolving door
into government stuff there's reason
always be skeptical but at the same time
when i when i when i read things in the
mainstream media that are out like
outright fabrications and then i go to
the cdc website the cdc says something
substantially more honest i say
substantially because it's ultimately
down to who you trust but
you go to uh the fda or the cdc what
does the fda say about the pfizer
vaccine community they have they have a
whole insert saying there's insufficient
data on pregnancies and there's no
long-term effects because it's now
entering long-term long-term trials the
fda literally says that they're not
hiding it from you you go to the media
and they'll tell you it's not true
they'll be like no no it was all done
it's like why are why the fda doesn't
say that i can go to their websites and
that was that was something that i think
was kind of big for me when
when i was looking up the appropriate
actions what do the what does youtube
say to do
that people should you should be not
advising medical uh treatments people
should be going to their medical
professionals
a lot of people say like oh but tim all
doctors are dumb and i'm like yo what if
you have a trump supporting doctor like
conservative doctors exist right you
don't think they're dumb i guess well
one one way you phrased earlier is talk
to someone that knows what they're
talking about i.e a doctor but the
problem is doctors don't know everything
and sometimes they learn only a specific
amount of information they know it
really well but they don't know and that
doesn't change the argument it doesn't
change go to a doctor i have no idea
what this is like why are you going to
him it's like like i always say you
don't go to carpenter to fix your toilet
that's why you should consider going to
lots of different doctors is my point i
guess because every doctor is going to
know a different amount of information
about different kinds i i think
i think youtube is scared of liability
i think they're terrified of it i think
when people say go out and say i'm not a
financial advisor they're they're
worried about liability i mean that's
why we say because we don't want people
to be like oh they advised me to do
something you got sick like if we come
out we told people to take some kind of
medical action and then they went and
did and got sick and died we'd be on the
hook for millions of dollars no no we
don't give medical advice i understand
that youtube's scared of liability i
think ultimately it comes down to the
bottom dollar talking like another
example of how this functions is we're
talking with uh chloe valderri she does
the theory of enchantment it's like
anti-racism training that's like opposed
to wokeness and critical race theory she
was saying the reason these institutions
are implementing this critical race
their stuff is not because they believe
it it's because they're scared of
liability
they're they're they're worried about
getting sued over so they're just like
bring the people and let them say
whatever they want
i think that's a big driving force in
this obviously big pharma wants to make
a lot of money they get guaranteed no
liability contracts with all the
vaccines and because of that
it sells distrust so ultimately i'm like
this
just because a big pharma is getting a
contract doesn't mean you should just
trust the other person saying something
wildly different that's why i'm like
dude don't let the culture war influence
your medicine like obviously do your
research
but you got to find someone who's
convincing like who's going to be like
let me show you the literature let me
break it down for you let me take those
partisans out of the picture and make
sure i'm giving you good medical when
you get people that abuse the literature
like cnn just did with this
thing saying yeah saying that it's it's
what do they say exactly what's the
thing the ticker the words that came up
taking livestock drug despite warnings
that is misinformation it's not
livestock drug and they deserve to be
sued i i don't want to say he should
because it's not me doing it it's a big
process to do it but if he sues them
this is this becomes a nexus point of
whether or not this stuff is is animal
feed livestock medicine
isn't there isn't there a part of this i
mean everything i mean you're you're i
agree with everything that you're saying
but like when when president trump
uh talked about
the potential of hide
hydroxychloroquine right right was that
what it was hydroxychloroquine it was a
z-pack yeah the combo z-pipe it felt
like the media just opposed it because
trump said it and there was no critical
thinking to go behind it like no
assumption that hey this is the
president of the united states like he
might be privy to medical information
that maybe at least in early stages that
we don't have but then after trump is
not president anymore there's what
studies that have come out that say hey
maybe hydroxychloroquine is well that
well so effect something somewhat
effective they were doing studies the
whole time and there was a promising
study out of france it's why trump
mentioned it and here's what happened
trump would read something in the news
say it and then immediately the news
would flip on the whole thing so it was
tech crunch right tech crunch reported
that the combination it was zinc and uh
azithromycin and hydroxychloroquine
was promising
not a promising is a long way to go
before it's before determining efficacy
and truth so trump was like it looks
very good we'll see and then immediately
they're like trump is pushing conspiracy
right and people are eating fish
medicine and all the other nonsense
you know i will tell you it is true
there have been anecdotes about people
who buy the horse pace protector supply
eat the whole thing
and i'm like
we get people saying like well you're
not supposed to eat the whole you're not
supposed to eat it it says on it you
can't even give it to a horse intended
for human consumption i didn't know
horse was like a commonly eaten thing
but it even says it's funny when it says
it says uh do not give to horses meant
for human consumption is what it says on
the box but what it means is do not feed
the horses that are meant for human
consumption and it says not do not feed
the horses period meant for human
consumption you see see how they can mix
that up right are they telling me it's
meant for human what does this say
no no don't feed it the horses that
you're gonna eat if you're gonna eat
exactly exactly exactly so uh
anyway the point is
when uh right now reuters it has been
reported actually a couple months ago
wrote his report that oxford is doing a
study on ivermectin which is promising
and so i'm just like
can we can we just chill you know do we
do we say like okay this is really great
oxford this is fantastic we got a bunch
of other studies there's data coming out
of other countries can we have a serious
conversation about this well the media
lies so that makes it impossible youtube
is paranoid and terrified of uh uh
liability liability issues so they go
nuts on it and then my ultimate thing is
like bro i don't think we should be
giving people advice on what they should
be ingesting anyway i think their doctor
should be doing that so if that if
that's the way to just be like
we don't get financial advice we don't
give legal advice we don't give medical
advice all right well there we go i'm
not even advising people to get the
vaccine because that's the same thing
and that's another big complaint i had
when casey neistat told me on twitter
that he pulls into a parking lot waited
for 45 minutes and stuck his arm out the
window to get a shot and i was like bro
did you talk to your doctor and they got
mad at me i get all these leftists mad
at me for saying talk to your doctor
about getting the vaccine because we
don't want adverse reactions we don't
want to hear these stories about people
anaphylaxis there was early on nurses
had anaphylactic shock from this and
then they were like okay maybe you
shouldn't get the second dose i'm like
well it's a good idea for people to go
to their doctor before getting medicated
but what you get now from the mainstream
left and this is what youtube allows
youtube will definitely allow you to
give medical advice so long as you're
telling people to get vaccinated without
going to their doctors which is insane
oh that they i don't know but this
this is my whole point this is the point
that i was trying to make
so the liability argument is perhaps a
compelling one and one that i i could be
swayed but
the point that i was making to you is
that some opinions are okay right some
are not and that right there like you
can get banned for saying something that
is counter to the media narrative like
you said like you said you could go on
youtube right now and and advocate for
people to get to get vaccinated right
without consulting their doctor um
that's okay you don't get censored for
that but any discussion of you know
promising medicine that is not approved
you get censored what that does
from uh from a societal standpoint is
create a divide and it sows distrust
well that's that's the more discourse
that's better right that is the
liability the reason so so here's the
important point in the rules it
specifically says
that you can't say there's a cure you
can't advocate for treatments and you
must tell people to go and talk to it it
doesn't say you must but it's like you
can't discourage people from seeking out
medical professionals or something like
that
the issue is
ivermectin uh a hydroxychloroquine zpac
are not authorized by the fda for use in
treating this because of that you can't
tell people to do it you know what else
is a huge problem with this is is the
our institute nobody trusts our
institutions anymore
and they have become everything's
political everything is political and
and and in fact that is a a goal of the
radical left is to sort of penetrate
institutions
and as a way to exercise some sort of
control over people and now nobody
trusts institutions anymore you can run
for your county treasurer and somebody's
going to ask you what your opinion on
abortion right that's where we're at now
that's true that's true but this is the
problem i have with the whole
with a lot of the debates over a lot of
things and that's why people are like
tim's a milk toast fence it i'm like
dude i'm not just going to say i trust
one faction over the other because i
don't trust one faction you know what i
mean like trust is earned so when it
comes to any kind of scientific research
i'm like i look at this and just say i
got to make sure i'm not getting my
information from culture war sources on
this one you know
if i go to my doctor and i say here's a
story what do you think and he doesn't
know about it i'll find a better doctor
if i'm like hey here have you heard of
brett weinstein's podcast what do you
think and if he's like i'm not sure i'll
bet okay maybe i need someone who's been
following all of this debate in this
news
there was a guy who was in the you guys
know the frontline doctors coalition or
whatever yeah apparently there's a guy
who like defected i don't know if that's
the right word but he's been critical
and he was speaking with this
progressive on youtube how
you know he's critical of the media the
media lies saying a lot of the same
things i'm saying and he was also adding
that it seems like some of these guys
who are advocating for ivermectin it's
become overtly political for them where
they're so angry at the media for lying
about horse dewormer and livestock that
now they just assume anybody who
challenges the idea is pushing some kind
of narrative when in reality
there are studies that are promising and
there are studies that are saying
nothing that there was no impact or that
it ultimately didn't help at all and so
we're investigating trying to figure out
if it works but it's breeding zealots
the the there's it's the counter
identity right
we talked about this again with chloe
that some people are have
counter-dependent identities where their
identity is based upon hating the other
group and that's why i'm like look man
you can believe that the right tends to
be more honest in their media and the
establishment left is lying nonstop
that's true that doesn't mean you can
just assume certain science is or isn't
correct without going through it and it
also means for someone like me i'm like
when i had when i had chris martenson
here and he was like look at the studies
that say this i google searched the
opposite and found studies that said the
opposite and i'm like what should i what
should i blindly trust you when i can
find a bunch of other studies saying
something else and then am i supposed to
assume all those other studies are
conspiracies i can't do that i literally
can't
throw my hands up go to a doctor man i
have no idea
that simple thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you